hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream q a segment 132.
let's go let's go all right
uh we're going to keep it tight today
because we have places to be we and
things to do and places to do places to
do things
and be yeah
we will be there inherently as we do
things
yes
okay
from the discord this week where every
week they vote on uh some questions have
been posed and the top vote getter gets
asked of us and we
get answered of them uh answered at them
at them this one is for you all right
great response carol greider's
you may have to just give some
background i'm going to just read the
question as written
grider's paper didn't find a correlation
between telomere length and lifespan
telomeres do not seem to be a
significant limiting factor in the
lifespan of mice
and jackson labs claims we now know
there isn't a big correlation between
telomere length and lab versus wild
so on what empirical basis do you claim
that lab mice have a quote preternatural
capacity to replace issues
tissues
it may say issues but they mean tissues
i said tissues oh okay sorry i misheard
you i think i said tissues it says
tissues all right um so here's the thing
you actually do not expect
uh a longevity correlation
with telomere length above a certain
number and the reason for that is
because number of like telomeres
okay the the number being telomere yeah
and in fact
carol alluded to this in my first
conversation with her she said
effectively um all mice die of cancer
by which he meant all lab mice
and so the point is
once you have destabilized telomere
length what you get are animals that are
all dying from the other failure mode
right they have tumors from very early
on those tumors grow and eventually they
kill the animal
so
you don't expect a longevity correlation
in fact you expect the inverse what you
get are animals that die early right if
you fixed their telomeres they'd live
longer when they live to
maximum age they die early of cancers is
what happens and that's why you don't
see that correlation
and this is perfectly consistent
with
a pretty natural capacity to repair
tissues because
effectively tumors are
an over enthusiastic repair mechanism
they're a repair mechanism that gets
carried away with itself and
runs away and so these things all fit
perfectly with the model right you get
short-lived animals all die of cancer
that have extraordinary capacity for
repair the extraordinary capacity for
repair
being the ugly downside of a infinite
capacity to replace tissues damaged by
toxic insult or or other such things
the third
piece of evidence
provided in this question is jax labs
claims we now know there isn't a big
correlation between telomere length and
lappers as well i guess it's all the
same it's all it's all one and uh jack's
lab apparently does not track
telomere length um
so uh eric actually
talked to them about the telomere length
in their colonies and they could not
give him
a history of how that length had changed
over time interestingly so anyway i'm
not sure why anyone's listening to
jack's lab on this point they have an
obvious conflict of interest and a
studied disinterest in discovering the
impact of their
breeding methodology on their own mice
indeed they do
all right
first question from the darkhorse
submissions site
we have one that was asked twice in
slightly different forms i'm going to
read the one that was upvoted
maybe i missed something as you were
talking but i didn't hear you talk about
women who have had abortions and years
later regret having one or the truth
that it stays with them all their life
i've met many women who've had abortions
and are still haunted by their decision
i believe it's worth
noting
and i guess in the other version she
says um
to adds um who go on to either regret or
live with the scarring memory of going
through with the decision
uh you know there's there's a lot that
we didn't say on the topic and um a lot
that we have said elsewhere and even if
you include all the places that we've
talked about abortion everywhere we've
talked about it in writing and in speech
there's a lot more to say
it is certainly true that
many women who have abortions
think about it
throughout life and
and some of those women
come to regret it and regret will happen
unfortunately from many of our decisions
that we make
pointing out that
there is an option that some people can
choose that
some of those people who who choose it
and maybe in some cases feel pressured
into making the choice
will regret
does is not
uh
i don't see that it necessarily belongs
in every conversation about abortion i
do think that it's disingenuous
and
really mean-spirited actually uh for
some on the left who are at the extreme
end of the spectrum
to talk about things like celebrating
abortion
we you know any any human being who has
thought about what we are and what
organisms are
should prefer that this not be something
that has to happen very often at all
the same i would hope would be true for
litters of puppies uh and for and for
any of our other domesticated animals
and for wild animals as well
you can take that you know every
everyone will draw a boundary in a
different place with regard to which
kinds of life they they care about and
which they don't or in what order they
put those those kinds of care but
i
have certainly
met women who have
lived with
the choice that they felt that they had
to make
throughout their entire lives did not
regret it understand their lies to have
been um much much bigger more rewarding
in at least one case allowed them to
then have a family that they could plan
and could offer their children
a life that they felt was was worthy of
of their children that they would not
have been able to do had they
not been able to choose
early in their lives when they weren't
in such a position
and i've also met women who
did
wonder with some frequency what their
lives would have been and they'd make a
different choice made a different choice
neither of those is necessarily exactly
regret but regret happens too so you
know all of the diversity of human
responses to such a situation which is a
dreadful one to find yourself in
that is i am pregnant and this isn't
right
this this will be a problem either way
what do i do it's a dreadful position
and none of the choice shouldn't be easy
for the woman to grapple with but it
should be
um
easily available once the decision has
been made
yeah i i
think this is
exactly right
it's
it's a significant decision and
maybe maybe we should just leave it at
that i think the pretense that it is not
an important decision it's just a choice
like any other is
obviously wrong for most people and
um
maybe that even goes without saying or
it would if it hadn't been turned into
a political article of faith right
i guess that's that's part of what
and that that really is related to what
you were raising and we were talking
about in the in the main part of
this livestream today which is that
so much of what should be a normal part
of the conversation
has been a blur obliterated by the
political landscape and the political
landscape has been
created in large part and certainly
maintained and massaged and enhanced by
our two political parties
and for the most part
they don't care about these women or
those babies or those fetuses or any of
it it's about political winds and
maintaining
a
tribal duopoly in american political
space
such that you can always get people to
do what you want by by putting this over
their heads and saying what if you get
you got to vote with us because what if
and as you said in the first hour
some of that has been destroyed with us
some of their ability to bludgeon us
with you can't not vote blue or you
can't not vote red because this thing
might happen well it just happened
okay now what do we do now what kind of
bludgeon will they use what will they
discover next
yep and you know i
safe
legal
rare
and early yeah right that that's the
world i want to see that's right and uh
it's a world i'm you know i'm seen as an
opponent for advocating anything other
than it it's fine whenever
yeah
and
i do not have the data at my fingertips
here but there
there are ample
data
that suggests that when it is available
that abortion rates go down
that you you you find you know when
society has facilitated
um helping people plan
and plan will be read
by some as a euphemism here um but
helping people plan including when they
find themselves in the situations where
birth control has failed and uh they
cannot see their way to starting or or
expanding their family now that in in in
the broader societal context abortion
rates go down
and someone actually down here at the
bottom here said
somewhere i thought
this is a little bit related but uh
another question here if you kill a
helpless baby for convenience what does
that indicate regarding your attitude
towards minorities that sounds unrelated
that's
we'll get to that part of this question
especially given how ravenous the
alt-left is for abortion i the question
asker
writes impro safe legal and rare
and you added early and uh you know i
think
i think those are the four words we want
right and if
if you accept the data
which show that
when safe and legal
and
uh
when safe and legal
the
rate of abortions go down then you get
towards more rare when you make safe and
legal true
and the restrictions
um that will be in place in some cases
uh you know i i hope that we don't get
as restricted as some european countries
i think there's some some european
countries that are like at six or eight
weeks
and you know most women don't know
they're pregnant six weeks
whereas you know also i think the first
trimester is is is too early
because the genetic testing
uh that many women do especially uh
older you know older women as i was when
both of our children were
uh were born
um are at higher risk for uh genetic
birth defects and i'm not i'm not
suggesting that any that that anyone
should be forced to get the genetic
testing or make any particular decisions
if they if they get a result that some
people might make a different decision
based on
but for for many people
um in including us we had that testing
done which is right around um right
around the halfway mark
um and we were completely thrilled and
would have been heartbroken had it come
back abnormal and would have had some
very different
difficult decisions to make absolutely
um there's you know
there's no there's no guarantee as to
what it is that you will do when you're
faced with a situation that you've never
been faced with before no matter how
certain you are in advance and i'm not
even saying we're certain
but uh you know limiting the ability uh
for a woman to terminate to before she
would have the testing that might change
the decision that she would make
uh feels like it is
it is again disingenuous if you are
pretending that this is for the good of
of the woman and her existing family
which many people are pretending
uh so with regard to the other part of
that um question which i sort of went
out of order here but um
i think she i think this question asker
who has a female name but of course one
never knows says i'm pro safe legal and
rare says if you kill a helpless baby
for convenience what does that indicate
regarding your attitude towards
minorities
well i mean i would rephrase it your
attitude towards others and i do think
that there is others everyone not you
well minorities what does that mean you
know i think the point is people
are it's you know it is much easier to
be indifferent to people who are remote
to you in
you know however many ways there are to
be remote people who are physically
remote people who are culturally remote
etc so i don't know that minorities is a
good description of anything but the
point is we should be cultivating in
people
a sense of our shared humanity
and i do think that that is another
hidden element of this discussion which
is
if you pretend that this is a
unimportant decision
right that it's just another decision in
life and who is anyone to
tell anyone it's more than that
that it does result in
um
a
dehumanizing
impulse and i think that's that's the
reason that early is such an important
piece of this discussion yeah is that
you know
those who say well it's a baby well no
zygote is not a baby right the zygote is
a cell
on the way to being a baby right and so
there is some uncomfortable increase in
the humanity of of that
uh process
and there comes a point at which there's
so much humanity that none of us doubt
it
right and there's an intermediate point
at which some do and some don't and the
basic point is it is always better to be
biased towards the early end of that so
that there is no
uh or as little ambiguity as possible
yeah precisely because what we don't
want to do
is view other human beings with any kind
of indifference and there's also you
know there are questions about things
that are similar to humans in some ways
you know the way we treat animals in
laboratory testing right i don't think
that's a zero issue either right right
and it's not that i think
we are in a position to do away with
animal testing i think it's important
because there's certain things you can't
test any other way but
am i very uncomfortable with us
um
rendering you know the testing on
primates as uh an important issue that
you know it's a matter of industry it's
not a matter of morality no i don't
believe that at all
um so
you know these things are complex and
frankly i don't trust anybody who says
no it's simple um here's the answer
we've got it yeah
good
uh
sorry my uh
my screen is playing games with me again
here we go
how much of history and prehistory is
simply projection
we often cite ancient authors as factual
observers but they would have had their
own biases and errors
likewise we tend to anthropomorphize
critters
behavior and desires
and i think those are two
i see that they're related but i think
there's really two different questions
here
there's three okay what are the three
well
the reason
that we distinguish history from
prehistory and the distinction is
prehistory is that which is uh
before the invention of writing for the
culture in question so the idea is
a first person account of something
is not objective because people are not
objective but a first person account is
different from something that we
reconstruct
um in the aftermath
and then there's the question of the
anthropomorphousing of creatures and i
would argue this is
so
there's sort of a spectrum here right
a person was there they observed but
what we got was handed down through some
non-written tradition that involves a
lot of transmutation of whatever
actually happened to whatever we
recovered but we are inferring through
indirect means like through pot shards
or whatever um and we don't have to go
through
their understanding of what they were
doing right which is its own kind of
bias that is introduced so the arc you
know the archaeological record the
prehistorical record which is not a
perfect overlap but at least largely
overlapping
does not have the problem
of the people who you are trying to
understand having had the capacity to to
lie to themselves or you in the interim
between you them project them
communicating something and you
receiving a communication yeah and in
fact at the risk of alienating a certain
number of folks
um
the story of the virgin birth of jesus
shows us that even
in a culture that had writing it's not
like you're getting
a an objective report because what we
now understand is that the word virgin
is actually a mistranslation of the word
young woman
and that you know the virgin birth is a
mythologizing of an event that you know
didn't happen that way it can't
biologically have happened that way even
if you think
there's a tremendous amount of room
inside of biology you know we're talking
about
a a
male child of a female so biologically
even if the thing that has never been
known to happen in humans which is a
python genetic birth
could not have a female producing a male
right would not have had a female
producing a male and likewise you know
the uh
rising from the dead there's a whole lot
in that story that does not describe a
physical universe that we understand and
yes you can impose a deity on it and all
but um basically the point is look you
had a culture that had writing what we
got is a fantastic story that does not
match our understanding of the possible
okay that certainly suggests that what
happened wasn't literal
right um but it becomes in many ways
even worse if you have a culture where
you are inferring from pot shards rather
than even words
um well no but i think i actually i had
the opposite right it takes a
subjectivity out of it it takes a
subjectivity out of it and i'm reminded
of you know the joke
the joke that i used to give to my
animal behavior students because animal
behavior was one of the the things that
i loved teaching the most and and taught
and and provided the students the both
the education and the space in the
curriculum to do complete pieces of
research from you know the idea to the
hypothesis to the everything all the way
to the end the communicating the results
in both writing and
in a talk
and um
as they
you know we also do a lot of reading on
human evolution and society and behavior
and i would say to the students
well unfortunately with whatever animals
you're going to be studying for your
research projects you can't just ask
them we can't just interview them like
like anthropologists can and the you
know
the flip side of that is and therefore
what you see them doing is what they're
actually doing
now it is your job to interpret what it
means
and one of the
important and non-intuitive skills
animal behavior specifically is as you
are doing for instance a focal watch
where you are watching one particular
individual at a time
um for an individual organism at a time
you write down
depending on your particular recording
method you write down exactly what you
see them doing know what you think it
means so you write down the actual
interactions between two say male mental
frogs you don't just write down fight
now you might start encoding it after
you've seen it a number of times like
this is a fight but here's what i've
actually written down because if you
just write down what you think it is
then you go back later and you say oh i
got eight of these things really how do
you know well because i said it was a
thing and i've got eight of them like on
what basis did you make that claim i
didn't record that i just wrote down
what i thought at the time which was
that it was a fight and then you have no
data and you have no basis on which to
make any claim at all that what you were
actually seeing was a fight or
territorial or anything
um this is
sort of
this is made both easier and harder by
talking to humans
about what it is that they think they're
doing because
they will not only
deceive themselves they will also
deceive others they may deceive you the
ethnographer
as
as the informant from a population that
is being investigated by you know what
might appear to be like random white
people who've shown up and want to know
things about them
uh so that you know there's there's pros
and cons in each of these situations and
yes there's going to be bias but i think
it's actually going to be you know it's
one reason that seeking data from when
you're talking about humans seeking both
direct and indirect evidence
will help you map things onto one
another and see if they actually match
up
yeah
um i must say i
there is a kind of care that has to be
taken when understanding animals but i
often see people draw the line someplace
that i believe makes no sense
right yes in other words to the extent
that you are looking at a mammal
you are looking at a creature where
there is a justification for a certain
amount of extrapolation and if you are
looking at a primate it is even more the
case and this is proven
by jane goodall
who
uh
cracked the case with respect to
chimpanzees by virtue of the fact that
he did anthropomorphize them and that
basically you couldn't make progress if
you treated them uh as objects
and that you you know and then frankly
it's not subtle when you know when a
chimpanzee is angry at another
chimpanzee it's obvious and you are you
know
there is a limit to what you can
understand about why it's angry but
deciding that you don't even know that
it's angry is obviously absurd right
likewise i think i was describing on a
recent podcast
that um
a cat
may actually like to have its tail
pulled if you
um
if you lift up a uh
a cat by its tail not a not a cat that's
overweight if you take a cat and you
gently lift up its hindquarters by its
tail you can tell that it actually
uh likes it i'm not saying every cat
does what many cats do and you can tell
because when you put them back down they
circle back to have you do it again and
the point is you know there aren't a lot
of interpretations there the animal has
returned to the place that something
happened right not because it doesn't
want that thing to happen
so
anyway there's a lot that one can
confirm yeah and it should be a catholic
who knows you and who likes you and
knows that you know and like them as
well
um i totally agree with you about
anthropomorphism and that was that was
what i saw as the second part of this
question originally and
um i think i think it's franz duvall uh
who has said in several of his books
basically
what the hell is wrong with people who
claim that you can't anthropomorphize
animals you have to you have to if what
you're trying to do is understand their
behavior in their social systems because
pretending that we aren't humans doing
the interpretation
and pretending that we don't share
much of what they are
with them
is the kind of it's frankly a religious
style mistake you know imagine that
there's this discrete boundary between
what humans do and what everyone else
does is to forget that what you're
looking at is an evolutionary process
yep
um in fact i'll just add one more thing
which is that there is a very famous
philosophical piece i can't believe i'm
not remembering the exact title
something like what it's like to be a
bat by nagel yeah yeah and uh a teaching
partner actually inflicted this
um what i believe is a terrible uh yeah
what it's like to be a back what is it
like to be a bat um
from 1974. inflicted this on a class
that we were co-teaching and you know
there is an an element of warranted
caution in here but basically nagel's
point is oh you'll never know and having
studied bats i can tell you it's not
that dire there's lots you will never
know about being a bat
but there's also lots of stuff that you
can infer rather easily and
you know i'm not arguing it's not an art
figuring out where to draw that line so
that you don't over extrapolate but
hobbling yourself by saying oh a bat is
a very different creature and therefore
you couldn't possibly know anything is
absurd and the fact is um
at least in the realm of animal behavior
we
learn from those who do the job well not
those who champion the fact that no one
can do the job that's absolutely right
and and we acknowledge that it will be
more difficult to do the inference
that we are trying to do with regard to
animal behavior uh the more distantly
related the organism is yep so it's
harder it's it's harder to
know the mind of a frog
than the mind of a bat
harder yet to know the mind of a shark
a coral is really going to be tough in
part because they don't have a mind but
um you know what is it like to be a
morel
what is it like to be well
what is it like to be a morale probably
nothing
um so i mean then then the question
uh
presumes you are suggesting that there's
a a self-reflection and there's a
consciousness possible in which case for
some of these organisms the question
doesn't make sense even before you get
to morel right that probably doesn't you
know it doesn't make sense for a coral
either right well here's the tough one
is something like
a spider or an insect
if you see an insect behaving if if an
insect is trapped in a jar and it
behaves in the way an animal in the zoo
does and it runs some circuit and it
apparently has lost its mind
it isn't clear that the animal has a
subjective experience you can't rule it
out but it's really hard to understand
what would be enhanced about the
functioning of the creature if it did
have a subjective experience so it's
quite possible even under purely normal
functional circumstances right so the
problem is that lots of if an animal if
a mongoose in a cage and an insect in a
similar environment
behave in the same panicked or
stereotypical way
you can be pretty darn sure that the
mongoose has a subjective experience not
terribly different from yours
it is very hard
to make a powerful argument that the
insect has one you can't rule it out but
the point is there's a reason that an
animal that didn't have a subjective
experience would behave just like one
that did and that's because the
subjective experience is trying to solve
the same unsolvable puzzle as the
automatic experience
and so what i would argue is
you know you have a subjective
experience
you're pretty you're on pretty solid
ground to infer that the mongoose does
and when you get to the insect if you
don't recognize that you've got a
difficult puzzle that at least leaves
open the possibility that the animal has
no subjective experience but it is of
course possible that it does for reasons
you haven't figured out yet that's kind
of where the gray area is and you know i
really do look at insects this way and
spiders i look at them and i think
i can't rule it out but i can't
understand why it would be there and so
i have to be
agnostic really right i have to say i
personally doubt it but if you came up
with evidence that said oh it does have
a subjective experience i'd say oh
that's fascinating yeah
now and there's um
it's interesting that part of part of
what we have done sort of professionally
is
try to understand why
the subjective experience in in the
terminology you're using now some with
great overlap with theory of mind right
great overlap with consciousness
um
why it shows up where it does so when
you say insects and spiders at first i
think okay it's going to be all
invertebrates oh
except for cephalopods right what do you
mean so what do you what
are you going to do with cephalopods
what do you do with octopus and
and and some squid at least maybe uh and
then you know is it all vertebrates
that's all vertebrates it's not going to
be
i don't know
um sardines
right well
it could be
you're in sort of a similar position
as insects it's hard to see where a
sardine gets a value from a subjective
experience and if it doesn't get a value
then there won't be one
but what do you do with
a sicilian
right
i didn't know you're anti-italian no no
different spelling right yeah okay so
different sorry i'm proud to know just
that it is spelled differently having no
real idea how to spell either one of
them yeah no i'm not going to blow
people's minds who give any kind of a
crap at all about spelling the sicilian
to which you were referring is
c-a-e-c-i-l-i-a-n and it's one of the
three clades of amphibians that no one's
ever heard of so you've got frogs which
includes toads you've got salamanders
which includes newts and you've got
sicilians which are entirely pan
tropical except for madagascar burrowing
legless amphibians so what are you going
to do with sicilians yeah it's hard to
see where a subjective i'm pretty
solitary i think they have yes they have
maternal care they have good maternal
care but um but then they
they go do their sicilian thing
burrowing and
spending all their life they do the
godfather theme is now playing in my
mind as a result of
your terrible accusation of me but
um
but anyway so this is the real question
is you won't see subjective experience
is expensive to produce so you won't see
it where at least the ancestor of the
creature hasn't gotten a benefit for it
um but it's not the only way to get to
you know
rational puzzle solving
so
yeah
good stuff
all right
next question
i showed your gender software arguments
to a friend
tracing the etymology back to 12th
century a.d
but the friend insists that there is
only sex and all talk of gender was
invented by sexologist john money
can you elaborate more on this
yeah um
easily yeah there has to be a software
component whether we define it as
subordinate to sex or not because the
variability
between the two sexes in the different
behavior is so great right that is to
say within a sex the behavioral
variation within humans is so large that
we know it's transmitted uh at the
software level and so even if it didn't
have a separate term it's about damn
time that it did and it seems to overlap
what people
mean when they say gender so the
question is
is the fact of the abuse of the term
gender
substantial enough that we need to
invent a new term for the software of
sex or should we be doing what you and i
have been doing which is
trying to retain the meaning in the term
that we have rather than
surrender it to people who wish to abuse
it
yeah i guess i would add to that that uh
i don't i actually have not gone back
and looked at the etymology but i've
heard versions of this it's not always
in the same one but you know no the term
gender was invented by such and such and
such and such and that's really recent
and therefore gender isn't real
that argument falls into the same trap
it's effectively a postmodern argument
until we had language for the thing
there wasn't a thing
that's not right right like you know if
we have language for a thing there's a
good chance that there's a thing that
predates the language for it one
and
uh we know for sure that there are
behavioral ramifications of sex
more broadly since
lotto the software of sex but there are
behavioral modifications of sex
that are much more sort of fixed much
more fixed action pattern type stuff to
use an old psychological term in other
animals such as in sex switching reefish
where one when the sex changes so too
does and we just call it in non-human
animals not gender but sex role it's the
same thing
so
is it possible that gender was being uh
gender was invented as something that
isn't real and
recognizing what it should be
a bunch of people over in reality space
went oh i know what that is
and so we're going to use that word and
now there's confusion in part because
the original meaning of the particular
word that we're using was uh was
invented for something not quite right
it's possible that it doesn't change the
fact
that sex and gender use whatever words
you like but let's be clear about it
that sex is hardware gender is software
and
almost all organisms that have a sex
also have some aspect of a sex role or a
gender
all right
ro distorted politics for 50 years by
placing a more moral issue out of reach
of voters a return to federalism is the
only way to keep the country together if
you don't like your state you can vote
with your feet
i hate this vote with your feet argument
there's obviously an element of truth to
it but it obviously also has
uh
there's a there's a tone deafness to it
because
a there's a class issue not everybody
can up and move right that's a matter of
your privileged position the fact that
your job allows you to move it's also
not true that us simply moving to some
place where the legislature is more in
line with how we
see the world
is a good way of going about things in
fact there's a strong argument to be
made that the fact of people
moving to the place that their job took
them was very distorting of the things
that united us and made us more
functional
and
that said
i you know there there is a value to
states having leeway under
the federal rubric
so
i think both things are true but i hate
the idea that you know it's like when we
were kids
if you made a
an argument something that the uh
country was doing was wrong then the
point was well why don't you move to
russia
don't do that
sorry no
um
so anyway yeah yeah it's good to be able
to vote for with your feet if you have
to but it's hardly a
a a good remedy yeah indeed
so zach i know you're working on the um
the video component that's gone kind of
wonky but it's just a little the one
that we're left with a little bit wonky
here it's a little bit tilted yeah i'm
making sure we'll still have audio all
right do and we have audio now yeah
wait
that takes out the audio
why is it dead
let's uh we're gonna we're gonna go make
it even briefer than we thought i'm just
gonna pull a few more questions then
okay uh just in case we're about to
lose
uh
hold on i need to talk to zach zach
switch to this i'm doing that
don't worry i'm doing this
okay
do
we all right
we could do a pamphlet i think they can
hear you for now
thumbs up if you can hear us no they can
hear you but this isn't working okay
i'm gonna just keep going i stand with
dr roligator and we'd like to see a duel
between peterson and trudeau pistols
is it pronounced rapiers yes or banjos
it matters not to me
now i don't know if jordan peterson or
justin trudeau are musicians but i hope
they both are and i'd love to see
i'm pretty sure jordan is yeah yeah
are we on are we on this audio right now
okay
uh yeah that wasn't really a question
just an observation like to see a duel
between peterson and trudeau mm-hmm yeah
okay dominating dad you want to go onto
the next one no i think it's a cool idea
i just uh you know
i got nothing more okay
my insurance just hit me with a huge
bill because apparently preventative
vitamin d tests are no longer covered i
wonder why keep up the good work you do
that's terrible
sorry it's ridiculous preventative
vitamin d tests are no longer covered
i'd like to hear you know two more
anecdotes like that before i know it's
not some
glitch in the system but right that
seems absurd for any organization that
benefits from making you healthier so
you use less insurance yeah
ancestrally if the youngest kid stays
longest in the mother's bed instead of
sleeping together with older brothers
and sisters as soon as mom gets a
newborn
newborn
does that create the condition for a
different perception of kinship
um
yeah i would say this is one among many
issues of birth order
where
the the way to think of it either birth
order has to be one of two things
it's either a male adaptation
where
something
there's either some best way to be
and being born
at a different place in the birth order
distorts you away from it that makes
little sense but it's possible and the
other thing is that it's an adaptation
where um
being born at a different place in the
birth order changes what is best for you
to be and so you end up different
and um
the fact is one size is not likely to
fit all
for one thing if you're born later in
the birth order you're born into a world
that has your older siblings in it and
therefore the niches that you might
inhabit are different
um you also know some of
you know
what jobs are taken care of and which
ones are open maybe that's the same idea
but
but in any case the
last born not being evicted from the bed
because no new one has arrived a that
won't always be the way it is but to the
extent that
it is it may actually speak to a
different relationship between the
parent and the offspring and their role
in the family
um so now and you would predict that to
happen for instance in cultures where it
is expected that the last born
um at least if of a particular sex will
be the one to stay and take care of
their parents and their dotage yep
absolutely
do we still have real uses for non-stem
paraphyletic groups in classification or
are they just a relic at this point wait
wait wait try that again do we still
have real uses for non-stem
paraphyletic groups in classification or
are they just a relic at this point
so i'm thinking um
you know birds
that doesn't include dinosaurs
is so stem does not mean
it's not the acronym it's not the
acronym oh okay yeah
then i would say and we don't but some
of them are so like
birds
what what is stem and what is not stem
infection systematics depends on your
vantage point right it's it's it's a
question of where you're standing
and so you know birds are birds stem
it depends
but you know so in in common parliaments
we're going to continue to talk about
birds and um
or i said that backwards
right yeah birds are monophyletic yeah i
said i said it backwards i mean
dinosaurs not including birds yeah so
dinosaurs as usually understood by
people
is paraphyletic
and usually you would say non-avian
dinosaurs if you're talking to
systematists or you're not just like us
and you're just talking to the world um
but
dinosaur is understood enough by most
people that you know at a conference on
dinosaurs you're not going to have
people continuing to talk about
non-avian dinosaurs usually when they
are meaning to exclude birds
so
i mean i have made the argument and i
still believe although it is a
i got strong pushback on it there is
zero defense
for
paraphyletic groups there is no problem
saying non-avian dinosaurs that says
what creatures you're talking about
without making a phylogenetic error and
the reason that it is so important that
we speak in a rigorously phylogenetic
way
is that it does all of the heavy lifting
or most of the heavy lifting in terms of
teaching people what kind of a process
adaptive evolution is
in other words
you know to know
uh that cetaceans
are
uh ardiodactyls tells you what kind of a
process selection is because it's the
kind of thing that can take a
terrestrial ardiodactyl and turn it into
a whale right
so
it is it is difficult to come up with a
taxonomy that is perfectly
rigorous in cladistic terms and the
reason is because of the very fine grain
we're still learning who's related to
whom well and even i mean there's some
big ones like testodies which is the
group of turtles and tortoises
um there are still real arguments about
exactly where it goes and there was a
moment uh 20 years ago or so where
we pretty much thought we knew where it
went within the vertebrate tree like
they're reptiles we got that the
reptiles um but exactly where like which
other reptiles they're most closely
related to is still still in question
and so
their placement
will change what thing is paraphyletic
relative to them or whether or not they
are paraphernalic relative to something
else and since we don't know yet we will
continue to use the language that we
have
you know with the understanding if we're
trying to have a systematic conversation
it will be accompanied by a tree or
several trees which are hypotheses of
relationship between the organisms that
we're speaking about yeah
so i guess the point would be
pending complete information we have to
be somewhat tolerant of
slight
imprecision or unavoidable imprecision
but to the extent that we know who is
related to whom
we should absolutely endeavor to be
perfectly rigorous in our taxonomy so
that it matches our cladistic
understanding
um because
everyone i mean you know do you really
want to deny children the understanding
that they are in the park looking at
dinosaurs
i i don't i think it's marvelous and i
think they're entitled to it and
pretending that those aren't real
dinosaurs because they're birds is
absurd i mean hummingbird is a dinosaur
how cool is that yeah
indeed
um we've got a few here that are not
exactly questions so um i don't know if
i'll just read them all right
well this one is a question but the
answer at least from my perspective is
no so are you familiar with herbert
marcuse's repressive tolerance
it hard codes the idea of rules for thee
but not for me as an overt and just
tactic and leftist ideology of course it
does of course marcus did that and so um
the question asker provides a youtube
link which we're going to go to now
have you been following james top
canadamarches.ca
no i think so um
and
vax versus unbacks transmission
susceptibility
benefits risks
love you guys i think maybe this person
just wants us to
risk risk rif on risks benefits
susceptibility and yeah versus unmasked
transmission well
i can
i can give you
an educated guess
which is absent
the vaccines
even this unusual virus
would have calmed down and become less
of an issue and that we are pushing it
around at a collective level in a way
that is causing us never to address the
problem
and
um
at whatever point we
stop doing that we will be better off we
need to unleash the drugs we have that
work so that we have another tool it's
not like
um you know vaccine or fend for yourself
it's
these
remarkable vaccines with all of their
downsides or a bunch of drugs we know
really well that are also effective
that's a much better world but it's a
world we don't get to see um
yep
so yes in light of
uh antibody dependent enhancement uh
original antigenic sin
uh and a number of other processes it
does not make sense to keep playing this
game we are making we are this is now a
self-inflicted wound several times over
even after we get past the lab leak
indeed
okay couple more comments a couple more
questions and then we're done
for today all right
some societies
right sam have social pressures against
extramarital sex
yes they do as i think we mentioned
the u.s second comment u.s needs to
resolve abortion the state referendums
removed from the political
it's not clear to me that uh state
referendums are removed from the
political
i think i understand the point is being
made but uh yes having grown up in
california i will say they are hyper
political and and in some ways they're
dirtier and california is such a giant
economy it's
it's not tiny but they're just they're
they're nasty and deeply political
and
of course in california it also has
cascading effects on the rest of
everyone yeah i mean there's also this
other issue though that
i believe it's referenda
that referenda are liable to be
inappropriate because they are so easily
politicized and that in essence a
representative democracy is one in which
people who are well positioned to know
what these issues are about
rule on our behalf which isn't the same
thing
exactly as us ruling on our own behalf
but it is
it is designed to do that same job
and you know i i think one of the
the arguments
that was strongest against roe was that
it was effectively the job of the
legislature to figure out what we
collectively need done on this issue and
that it was done through the courts
on
you know a bad premise
and so
uh
good law that actually did navigate
what we collectively believe and as much
as possible
protect
all
viewpoints that can be reconciled
would be a good thing yeah um but
you know i think we've been we've been
jerked around by political parties that
are way too interested in making us
understandable to each other and they've
done a good job
and ultimate question
why is abortion such a big deal but
killing animals for meat is not
well
it has a lot to do with the fact that
uh fetus has become
human fetuses become people yeah and so
it is in essence it goes back to the the
issue that we were talking about
what i was calling sleight of hand
where we take people who have resulted
from
you know pregnancies that have gone to
term and try to infer back
there is
a valuing of human life over other life
uh that is both uh
intuitive to most humans
and also
repugnant uh to many humans if they
think carefully about the basis on which
they're doing it and the exception in
that former group will be that many
religious people will say it's it it
ought to be that way because
uh because human life is sacred in a way
that other life isn't
uh for the majority of us who don't
believe that and don't
believe in a special class for human
life
um above and apart from all of the other
life
uh then there's the additional
there's the additional question of sort
of helplessness
but of course we domesticate animals and
uh for meat and turn them helpless
so i really do think it is about the
special the special category of
humanness yeah i think it is i also
think that that is appropriate i don't
think it's absolute
right at the point that we treat
elephants or chimpanzees or gorillas
with indifference i think we make a dire
error
but there is something very special
about humans it is also you know if we
want to
sort of push the concept around to see
how robust it is
you know why are we indifferent to the
killing of plants
right is the killing
of a plant really a non-issue just
because it doesn't experience something
you know
i mean i think it is a non-issue but but
the point is if that's the deciding
factor
domesticated animals have a great
evolutionary deal right they've
come to
outnumber their wild counterparts by
many many orders of magnitude and if you
raise them i think
you know raising them inhumanely is a
uh is a serious moral question but
raising them humanely and killing them
humanely for food
uh is not
right
so anyway
there's a lot of richness to this
question
but i also think there's an intuitive
um most of us know
that raising an animal in a cage where
it never sees the light of day
um there's something wrong with that
even if we can't explain exactly what it
is yes and and you know i think we also
most of us understand that raising an
animal
outdoors in a pleasant setting and then
it's ceasing to be at some moment
isn't a terrible fate i mean you know we
all live and then cease to be at some
moment yeah right
um so anyway
there are difficult questions here but
we shouldn't make them more difficult
than they are that's right
final question
what type of prophylaxis or precautions
do you both take prior to traveling
this has been changing
right are they are they talking about
code i think i i
i read the question as it exists uh i i
can't see more into it than the words i
read but
i take it to be that and i don't think
uh you know neither of us prophylaxis
with anything in particular before covet
unless we were going into
malaria territory and i've talked before
about some parts of those are supposedly
malaria territory not actually being
malaria territory
uh and therefore you're not necessarily
needing the malaria prophylaxis um
that you do if you're going into that
you are very much better protected by
even as toxic as most malaria
prophylaxis is
by taking what's well enough in advance
before entering the territory so that
you're protected from malaria
um in except for that we never
prophylaxed with anything uh in advance
and you know i think we both found three
four maybe five different types of
malaria prophylaxis as
as our collective understanding our
individual understanding of how they
work and on what species of malaria and
all of this have have evolved
um
but for coven
well a there wasn't much traveling there
for a while
at all and it's still it's still pretty
slow it's still pretty uh
spotty
uh but through
i don't even know if it went either of
us went anywhere in 2020 i can't
remember um after after covert hit but
in 2021 uh you in particular were going
some places and
um
you're pro flexing with with ibm
yep and being you know very careful to
keep your contacts
uh before going uh low limited yep
vitamin d
better if you can get it from the sun
um
avoiding indoor spaces
if you have to go into indoor spaces
while traveling or before while
traveling
uh
the higher the volume the greater the
circulation actually traveling but in
terms of the preparations which is what
the question was about
um avoiding those spaces in advance so
that you're less likely to um carry
something to a new location because it's
not
if you're traveling you are now taking
on a burden uh that at one level is not
you know you're taking a responsibility
that you need to take seriously that you
are now at risk of exposing people who
have no choice in the matter and so you
need to be as
unlikely to be infected with a pathogen
as possible when you travel and that's
true under all circumstances
but
just as the world probably now
understands
that going into work when you're
actively sneezing and coughing from a
pathogen is not a good idea for your
co-workers and probably not for you
either
so too does um being knowingly exposed
say uh to coven and then getting on a
plane the next day that's that's really
not okay that's that's not okay whether
or not you feel fine but it's not yours
to take
um
to expose other people without their
having a say in it yeah i wish we
had had this conversation more
explicitly
with respect to all sorts of things
right we basically need to have a
general policy
that causes people not to interact with
each other when they have an illness
beyond a certain level right do we want
that to be a cold maybe not right maybe
we all agree that we're going to get
colds
uh but yeah what what is the beyond a
certain level you know
you're not going to get on a plane with
typhoid
right
uh you're not going to get on a plane
uh
with yellow fever and a swarm of uh
anopheles mosquitoes around you
because it's just yellow fever there's
no mosquitoes you're actually not at
risk to other people okay
um
flu probably not cool not cool
cold
okay and so now what is covered becoming
covet is actually
ridiculously stupidly dangerous because
of the franken virus
so it's not just like oh it's another
coronavirus
on the other hand it's becoming so
ubiquitous it's evolving so quickly
that
people are getting
you know both exhausted of and
sloppy about
being careful yeah i wouldn't say
it's stupidly dangerous people are gonna
flag us for that i would say it is more
dangerous than the case fatality rape
it's stupid
let's put it this way there's an awful
lot of unknown about how dangerous it is
by virtue of the fact that it does not
appear to be a natural virus yeah
yeah so you know the
i think at this point
caring
carry with us the two early treatments
that are available over the counter
uh ibm and hcq
uh just in case
and uh when traveling maybe go back on
that dose of of
supplements that at this point seem
pretty smart to take if you live
in a temperate zone where it gets dark
and cold in the winter such that you're
unlikely to be generating
uh that much d yourself and are likely
to be in enclosed spaces with other
people who might also be bearing viruses
so that's like d and c and zinc and
magnesium and
quercetin
if you get the kind that's actually
bioavailable
yeah
all right all right i think we're there
we are not going to be here next
saturday but we will be here the
wednesday after that which will be on
july
going to keep on delaying until i can
see that it is going to be july 6th july
6th july 6th yes
uh we're not sure exactly when yet but
on july 6th we will be back
here with you
in our in our usual location i believe
and until we see you then please do
subscribe like share talk about discuss
uh dispute disagree with agree with
and
be good to the ones you love
eat good food
and get outside and have a great fourth
of july if you're an american and if
you're not also have a great fourth of
july
[Music]
you